on that interception i was pretty
nervous i'm not gonna lie to you guys
but after that
you know put it behind me i think
you know that
after the crowd got really loud after
that pick it was just you know oh shoot
and then i was like okay here we go you
know can't get much worse than that so
you have a feeling you didn't say shoot
after that interception after the crowd
got loud first throw of his regular
season career looking like brett favre
the bad brett favre rolling right
telegraphing left throwing it across the
field pick six seven nothing and of
course the jets go on to win 48-17 just
like we would have expected in that
moment peter king
you know the thing that you you saw
you know steve young said it at half
time and and and farva said it too in
the wake of his disastrous interception
uh you know against the saints in the
championship game eight nine years ago
i i think the biggest thing that
happened
to sam darnold is that
essentially
he said to himself look you know i'm
better than this i'm going to be better
than this i made a mistake it's not
going to ruin my night and that's what
happened from there on out but i will
also say this
you know that that this was the uh the
the definition of a team win you know
special teams played great uh obviously
the defense with five picks matthew
stafford was
i i don't know where he was i don't know
who he was in this game
but it was very very clear and
afterwards mike the jets were saying
they knew
what the lions were doing and that in
the first game of a season with a new
regime has got to be driving matt
patricia crazy this morning
you know peter it sounds like you're
saying that sam darnold put himself
through the stuart smalley pep talk i'm
smart enough i'm good enough and dog
gonna people like me and it worked
to me when i'm watching when i'm
watching sam darnold play
you know other than that one
snap that first snap of the game the
idiotic play
uh you know he looked like a veteran
quarterback and so all the people who
have said that he's the answer you know
i think for one night at least they got
a positive look and and mike by the way
i was out early this morning walking the
dog in new york and here's what we have
i just wanted to share this with you
because it's just like
everybody in new york is saying okay we
got our guy for the next 15 years it's
all over
but again and again i'm not in any way
throwing shade at anybody or or or
diminishing his performance because he
was very very good beautiful deep
touchdown throw to richie anderson
uh but but
other than to say it's one game this was
a game that was probably more
uh of a complete team win than anybody
had in week one of this season
and that was the new york post headline
he's darn good and peter i think it
helps tremendously to have a 10 million
dollar assistant quarterback coach and
josh mccown who was there all the time
working with him talking to him
interacting with him on the sideline
throughout the game i think that went a
long way toward calming sam darnold down
and allowing him to be and think about
how often have we had this where there
is a first-round rookie quarterback with
a veteran who is there for one reason
only and fully embraces and owns it to
help that guy be the best he can be
usually there's tension jealousy
resentment whatever this is josh mccown
all in in the effort to help sam donald
and i think that went a long way toward
getting him to forget about that
interception and move on with the game
that we saw him have
there's no question about it if you look
back at his recent history josh mccown
you know you go back and j you remember
when he was playing really well in
chicago and jay cutler came back
and uh and they gave the job back to jay
cutler instead of letting mccown keep
playing
uh he's and then he did it in cleveland
remember how uh johnny manziel said you
know he's the best thing that happened
to me when i was in cleveland uh it
didn't work out but everybody who has
been around
this guy has basically said
he is the absolute perfect
quarterback to learn from sam darnold is
just the latest guy again who's the
beneficiary of the most unselfish guy i
think i've covered in my years covering
the nfl mic
yeah and look
who knows maybe the lions are the worst
team by far in the nfl this year and the
jets are going to continue to struggle
but for one night
the the jets
created the kind of buzz we haven't seen
them create in a long long time so it
was a good night for jets fans let's
flip it over to the lions peter we did
that little two-minute stub on the way
in on nbcsn the radio audience hasn't
heard this your observations of the
lines you went to a lot of training
camps and you saw something when you
visited with matt patricia's team that
gave you pause what was it
the fact that uh on the first two long
series of the practice that i saw
they just they were all in on the
running game uh
you know legarrette blount carried it
like three of the first four snaps in 11
on 11 that day and
and then they had another series against
the defense that
that was
was dominated by the run and i walked
away saying matt patricia is
trying to tell his team listen we all
know that matt stafford can throw for 5
000 yards quite frankly i don't care the
only way you win in this league is to be
able to make it second and four and
we're going to be able to run the ball
well and last night they were terrible
at it
you saw it right from the start
and to me and and add to the fact
that their franchise left tackle taylor
decker
gets uh uh
it basically gets caved in
and might have gotten
matt stafford's left knee injured you
know we don't know yet probably not but
i
this is something that the detroit lions
and the past
generations of detroit lions have tried
to solve the problem of life after barry
sanders in the running game and on the
offensive line
look barry sanders and lomas brown are
not walking back through that door again
and the lions i applaud
matt patricia for trying to re-uh
institute a really strong running game
in a very good offensive line but boy
did they look awful last night you have
to just say listen it's one game
and if you're the lions
that's as depressing to me
it's more depressing than the bills game
uh than what buffalo did because buffalo
at least
saw sean mcdermott last year in year one
lead a woe be gone franchise to the
playoffs so they got some faith that the
guy knows a little bit about what he's
doing
you know to the detroit lions fans
waking up this morning matt patricia is
simply another failed
bill belichick assistant who went on and
couldn't have success anywhere else and
look he's got a he has to prove now
that
this was a one-week blip on the radar
but it also falls on jim bob cooter to
make sure
that the jets are an outlier and if
they're saying hey we knew what was
coming they better not know what's
coming in the next few weeks in detroit
yeah that was the comment from jets
linebacker darren lee after the game we
were calling out their plays as stafford
was getting up to the line of scrimmage
we knew his signals we knew everything
that's just preparation as a defense it
seemed like we were in his head as a
defense they attributed that to film
study now if it were the patriots of
course people would assume something
else but for the jets film study film
study film study and that's not a good
look on jim bob cooter when matt
patricia got the job there was a
question is he going to bring in his own
offensive coordinator or is he keeping
jim bob cooter i think maybe he got
nudged a little bit to keep cooter and
he may be regretting that this morning
there's something to be said for getting
your own guys in there and for getting a
fresh start but you know the offense
wasn't deemed to be broken at least the
passing game the passing game was
dreadful last night and the running game
still as bad as it's been as you
mentioned peter 39 yards 15 carries 2.6
yards per carry and the big free agent
acquisition legarrette blount had minus
three yards on four attempts
well
let's just say one thing about about
matt patricia and jim bob cooter
i think there's two things at play here
number one when matt patricia came in he
had a conversation
uh
you know with with matt stafford and
basically i think stafford really gave
his seal of approval to cooter number
two i don't think that matt patricia had
a guy
to run his offense it's not to say he
couldn't have found one but i just don't
think he had a guy who he was dying to
hire and so
if you if that's the case look
patricia can always make a change at the
end of this season he can always go and
you know sort of reconstitute daryl
bevel or or whoever it may be he can he
can bring somebody else in you know to
run his offense but i just think he
didn't have anybody else mike at the
time that he really wanted
you mentioned bill belichick earlier
patricia the latest guy to come from
that tree and one of the reasons i
thought the lions would win and possibly
win big last night bill belichick 9-0
all-time against rookie quarterbacks
while playing at home so here's the
youngest rookie at least since the
merger to be starting of course matt
patricia is going to have picked
something up from bill belichick over
the years on how to deal with a rookie
quarterback right out of the gates and
no no owen won for his career 0-1 at
home against rookie quarterback so there
goes that one and this is going to dust
off that question peter and we've seen
it time and again former bill belichick
assistants just don't thrive beyond new
england
yeah i think it's i i think we have to
look at this and say look there's
definitely evidence
uh you know of guys who were in the bill
belichick on the bill belichick tree
both coaches and general managers the
only one you can look at and say he's
really had a good run is thomas dimitrov
the general manager of the falcons but
everybody else has really struggled
and and i guess i would just make this
point about all that and that is that
look with the exception
of all the guys who left and who moved
on
to a new job the only guy who's had a
quarterback a really potentially very
good quarterback is matt patricia
um and so
that's why i think that's stat i'm not
saying it's it's meaningless i i think
it's a little bit specious because in my
opinion
you know
so much of what happens in the nfl
depends on whether you've got a
quarterback so many of those coaches
haven't had one
yeah and again it is just one game you
throw out week one but to get blown out
like they did at home by jets team that
has been bad in recent years that is a
tough tough way to start the season
we'll see how they rebound and recover
by the way our friends at
merriam-webster
lambaste and lambast both appropriate
and accepted pronunciations of
best is liam best is so much better mike
because i said it
no i like lambaste because it makes me
think of turkey
very good very good i tried